We're going to start by picking a random d that has to be relatively prime to φ(n).
We can pick random numbers and test that this property holds and pick again if it doesn't.
Since d is relatively prime to the totient of n,
that means it has a multiplicative inverse in that group.
So we can find some value e such that d is equal to 1 mod φ(n).
There exists some value e such that de is congruent to 1 mod φ(n).
Now the question is given d and the totient of n
is it hard to compute e?
The choices are, yes, it'd better be hard. Otherwise RSA would be insecure.
No, it's easy. We can use the extended Euclidean algorithm to do this.
Or three--no, it's easy. We can just divide the φ(n) by d.